[Music]
dude that [ __ ] with brennan that was
[ __ ] crazy that was like the worst
game of clue i'd ever seen in the world
when you guys did that thing it's like
he had like these fought the files and
the full and you guys had like missing
people in the [ __ ]
there was some guy i like theo i don't
know
i can't not like the guy yeah feeding
kids on reddit yeah yeah i mean i can't
even get into my reddit how do you beat
kids yeah like the that was the [ __ ]
the whole thing was unbelievable the
whole thing was unbelievable and i was
just like you know i don't
i don't want this [ __ ] to be [ __ ]
happening
but it was [ __ ]
i know it was pretty [ __ ] yeah the
whole it was
that's why i like theo vaughn because
he's the only one that's not playing
politics and not being stupid he's just
being like he's just left [ __ ] all
the party guys he's just laughing at all
of these people things they were saying
was like i had i wouldn't even i didn't
even know what the [ __ ] they were
talking about i was like
what read it and what's going on you
know and they got you're the one
yeah i'm the one and by the way i i will
say this
bobby there's a lot of things about him
that are hateable but i really do
believe he had no idea about any of this
no he doesn't strike me so he's spending
his time online astro turfing
pornography
yeah but why i mean i don't have a
computer
and then it's like i remember like
here's the funny thing brendan doesn't
own a computer
i bet you brandon owns a computer come
on
i know he doesn't own a computer he
doesn't and then i remember dalia
calling me and going dalia goes you
don't own a computer and i go
i know
right he doesn't know that yeah he
thinks i'm i don't even know how to log
i love
that all of these these self-indulgent
la comics think that everybody remembers
every little facet of their life by the
way i do believe it doesn't have a
computer fine but
your [ __ ] chick did
does and internet [ __ ] are like that too
by the way i love the i don't have a
computer but you have a phone right it's
the same [ __ ] it's a computer you know
it's just a very tiny computer right
exactly so i mean stop with that but
it's like oh everybody knows that about
me
everybody knows
yeah i'm telling you internet [ __ ] do
that too when they get mad that you
don't know all their lore and [ __ ] and
it's like
what do you want from me i do all these
shows every week i don't know what
you're doing yeah like you know what i
mean you got to tell me what you're
doing and i'll try to support it but
like when you just go oh you didn't know
about my whole entire thing with this
thing i'm like no why would i know that
i'm not gay yeah it's very good point
get into anything you know i mean anyway
you know i mean and i saw him i've seen
him a couple times and i've been very
cordial you know i mean hopefully
you know we can do this you know i mean
and get back but oh you don't take a
while i think oh i think you guys are i
mean it's
i've never heard him have any animosity
i don't think he ever does yeah yeah
vernon never really does have any
animosity towards anybody yeah yeah um
which is crazy to think that he came
from a fighting world where they had
that so much animation no actually it's
not crazy and you want to know why
because after talking to a few different
fighters and this is this is a defensive
kids yeah
thank you i've been talking a few
different fighters the one thing i'll
[ __ ] tell you is
fighters aren't aggressive and hate each
other you guys la comics are you guys
are way more bickering
i saw jake shields just get into an
interaction with some other fighter who
was bitching at jake shields and did you
see what his reply was no
hey you're still a fighter let's scrap
no i'm not [ __ ] he goes but okay but
let's just handle this and we'll be
finished with it and the guy backed out
of it i just thought it was really funny
because that's like that's it that's how
you handle it you want to fight or no
yeah i was saying that yesterday it's
like with the james what i'll take it's
like you know they when you once do i
just be like you want to [ __ ] go and
when somebody's really calm and they're
like sure you guys wanna fight you're
like whoa i was i was scared i was
[ __ ] around
you you accepted that way too quickly
steakhouse
that's something that's always
interesting about him but um
he's one of the hardest records
i know but that whole thing was just
[ __ ] absolutely [ __ ] i'm like is
everybody [ __ ] and now it's like yes
theo
go back to louisiana sir
everybody is [ __ ]
especially in l.a it's like it was like
the game of clue though it was like
somebody did it in the [ __ ] yeah yeah
i'm in a mop closet with a bad server
yeah yeah yeah i i didn't even know you
know yeah it was also like i was at the
time when they made the calls i was on
set shooting something and although it
was like it really just the timing was
really weird and it's like
whenever somebody's like you know accuse
me of something i didn't do right it
feels like traumatic almost like
more therapists more therapists talk
traumatic more therapist you know what's
traumatic
um
being in like a car accident with
another person in the car and they die
and you live
that's traumatic getting raped in prison
is dramatic
having another comedian go oh you know
your dogs be a little form like it's not
traumatic no
because you'll be like no i didn't no i
didn't that's it clipping a [ __ ] yeah
exactly shut up
because it's like the way they were
talking you know i mean it's like you
know they were like no
bully is the wrong word but they were
just really adamant about no they were
bullying you that's actually the right
word i i now i got to say well they were
bullying you you were clearly being
bullied by them and you were by the two
jocks yeah
about it and they had a lot of feelings
behind it well they believed it i don't
think they i think these kind of maybe
still do i don't know i
that's [ __ ] hilarious
[ __ ] these you think they still believe
it
i don't know that means they still
believe it
i don't know i feel like they still
believe it bernie and i haven't really
spoken about it much yeah i it's kind of
weird that'd be the only thing i talk
about with my friend i try not to talk
about it either but i don't know but i
thought the whole thing was just
whole i mean it was but it was
interesting too it's all it's all like
the world is just it's all this
it's all this crazy
just drama this play and we're just
taking
different paths through it
okay
man theo vaughn really is like a
hillbilly fortune cookie huh
a hillbilly yeah yeah yeah yeah really
yeah he's a hillbilly fortune cookie
yeah